[Music]
Joe
I
[Music]
let's go we know right now she drops her
weight let me teach hope you don't have
it energy right down where you got your
weight you see it's pulling it down but
we want to push it down okay
[Music]
so obvious okay so we comfort this with
you maybe goes like that so then you
paint those dude energy goes that way X
power goes down so your technique goes
on paint you can see this very important
it's mushy and she got yeah same thing
[Music]
so now you go the story goes over here
so you can't get directly I'm just
displaced by the nature of the purpose
of the sword the curvature of the
webpage and also the curvature of the
movement is this displacing with
rotational in general so this is going
down but there's a curvature to the
force and what is the energy on earth
centrifugal energy you see so this is
going down but there's a curvature to it
and this internal energy is what moves
this out in relation with the fact that
that's what was forward in this form
this hammer slow bird and energy balls
of least resistance and it goes out that
way once I am in the center but but I
don't I'm not changing that so as part
of this is the problem is you're like
these knees
just calm down come down don't move over
[Music]
you're trying to move
so there's a moment where the left hand
is the right hand but now it has to move
through the two phases it's going to be
going to Oregon so that's very often
this is not there
oh and now to start you're going to feel
the in face and
Leon
so there is a young face to your face
and in face to your face but then
there's the yen and the young and the
young and the games in the to that so
right now young left yet they're
starting to change but there's a harmony
between the two so I can't go like that
haystacks a harmony with this hand now
and I can't go like this
my my hands have to be in order can't be
doing this and he also is my body and my
hands already in and your transition of
my body is they give me down transition
so the movements are together with my
bottom
so his weights not over you see that so
wrong here we go whoa
this hand is doing it this adds this way
pass the parcel it down this side would
be pulling
you can feel the transition you're going
to feel the zero question ball
you go over here I can't get my weight
over that you see that's why this has
not :
this time is beauty to the reaction I'm
staying with him not so with when he
falls he brothers our number I just stay
with his arm well you can see this is
missionary dish that's the young are
born out there out from under me
oh go to the stance
do the standard technique do the
technique
okay
Hey consider this slow the game was do
they all be able to get see any now deal
the end give the amount that was the
girl was you guys made it take the guy
down professor
there's nothing about here here or here
you have
[Music]
I am going to talk but once I'm over
this and I'm trying to climb it once I
get over to top sander starts to draw
while I stand I got over the top a
little bit my butt and not staying over
the top hey so over the top this is
wrong but this is wrong over the top
goes down okay you're already starting
you probably miss hardware which already
pollution just leave them here honey
this hen goes this way honey this hand
goes in tune it's like stop Danny go do
mocking touch walk in touch with the
joke comes over it comes over the top
you see
he comes underneath DC Piper don't start
doing it right underneath you then this
hand will find its positive angle have
you seen okay not this hand chase over
get your weight go down over you okay so
go again this hand does it go it does
not go into it right this hand does
macchiato ready do you see that this is
it so that this handout will pass into a
young face like keep your head where
it's supposed to be but it's just
mechanics okay don't put it off here
right here okay now start to drop your
Center boom not your lunch box
this is doing money into us now you
deserve need to throw your elbow that
degree okay now you feel the positive do
you feel the positive angle there's to
see okay
keep that going Center drop drop okay so
I'm not trying to get him off our stand
down thing with James it's just me
working the mechanics so you don't have
to take deep breaths
stand up that's your other matter okay
move it at this time
the he's going to if you begin aspect
you see in the absorption and then
you're going to get to if they go home
say and then you drop it so we grab the
heat wool but there's the positive angle
low don't get
[Music]
it doesn't bother okay no better pushy
oh you should work on it
so I could either stay there you would
cut here if you want your there
[Music]